hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm stealing another game from
yamimash
early say I think I am I don't really
remember where I downloaded this one but
this is purgatory 1.9 so let's play it
okay
dropping me right in a so let's see what
this is all about I only saw the only
nice play T he's been fighting all these
like interesting unique games so I don't
know where he's finding him Ollie's must
have better resources and I my my fan
needs to step up their games my normal
suggestion guy has not suggested much in
a while so anyway we're in a hall looks
like old Castle Wolfenstein or something
I've been having bad luck with the
videos today failing left and right and
up and down and I can't get anything to
go right I don't know why like
everything hates me everything hates me
but I'm trying to get by I just know
that something's gonna pop out on one of
these corners can I sprint yes I can
I've got three lives in one health but
you can't see that because my face is
covering it up I don't think it matters
I know I only have one elf I must have
been badly damaged when these doctors
experimented on me I'm just making up
story as I go I was lost in the woods
and these doctors found me and struck me
in the back of the head with a blackjack
and knocked me out next thing I knew I
woke up in a hospital bed chained to the
bed they were experimenting on me
injecting me with strange drugs next
thing I know I woke up in this strange
place with repetitive always okay what
am I looking for here this purgatory
just walking through a series of empty
alcoves not even rooms that's old
indentation
hi hello voices in my head the voices in
my head were growing louder I first say
were just whispers and okay that wasn't
a voice in my head Tom stop I'm gonna
stop trying to film noir this thing and
focus on the task at hand which is the
fact that there are diabolical entities
oh this is different oh I have a choice
well since I've been looping him back
and forth I'll take the other route I am
bad I thought that thing was coming
right for me this is obviously the
correct way what all right let's go for
it man go for it Britt oh yeah see
nothing nothing a whole lot of nothing
seems like I'm just wandering mazes I
wonder if you just put all these
indentations in here just to give it
some variety don't really know but all
right then and now somebody here is
there an end to this game is there an
objective method to the madness maybe
hello hello I'll go this way
okay this one seems like the longest
haul of all I'm getting you like a zoo
zoo just a little unsettled please don't
jump out and scare me my heart can't
take it like I said before I was trying
to record these not this video but a
couple other videos and things weren't
working out it wasn't recording right
I've had a string of those kind of
problems don't know why just have and
now oh what's this a straight hallway I
can't be right
oh it's just a curves off man why am i
doing here I guess I'll go this way it's
the only one that's been straight with
no alcoves it's really dark though oh
there are my lovely alkyls okay okay is
anything actually gonna happen wait what
okay now they actually go in little
squid uh-huh hmm okay everything's
getting a lot more convoluted things are
actually kind of opening up if I look
over here yeah things are actually kind
of opening up I'm assuming it's gonna be
a good sign but then I think I'm wrong
oh okay I hope I don't look back to the
beginning somehow that feels like it
would be a high probability of happening
still don't know what's going on other
than on that I am in purgatory
okay
what
ah
oh I lost a wife
well my lives counter it says I lost one
Oh screw that I was horrible did I hit
like a timer did I actually run right
into him I think he appeared in front of
me as I was sprinting forward in holy
crapola I'm just gonna sprint from now
on because I don't think there's a
cool-down and oh my god
screw that man did not like that at all
okay all right moving forward as fast as
I can I think I'm just looping through
the same halls as before except now I
have super dream Oh vision engaged which
is a nice feature I suppose makes
everything a little wobbly feeling
nauseous
I guess nausea is the least of my
problems in this place I'm what kind of
wondering what happens when I run out of
lives cuz I don't think there's a way
out of here or if there is it's almost
impossible to find oh well I will find
my way sooner or later I will either go
I think I made a right turn there so
let's go left this time see what's down
here I really wish the super dream Oh
vision would go away it's slightly
annoying don't know why it's like
permanently stuck maybe it's sort of
representative that I am stuck in in
limbo or something I don't know it's
keep moving forward just keep moving
forward nothing can stop me now
except for the monsters and the whispers
and the madness basically pretty much
anything can stop me now now that I
think about it
I think I hear this slight crunching
like you know the sound in amnesia when
you're going in when you're standing in
the darkness that's supposed to be it's
supposed to sound like bugs munching on
your brain I read an article of an
interview of frictional games and their
intention for that sound was supposed to
be like bugs crawling inside your head
and nibbling on things crunching
crunching okay I have a feeling the
monsters closed whatever it is it's just
a black shadow basically but I'm pretty
sure that it can kill me dead very very
easily you know this was the sort of
dream sequence that I saw that I had
when I was looking at the monster during
that one point a little bit ago but oh
come on oh god I thought that was it I
thought that was the end huh I'm okay at
least for a little while longer I'm
going in the same loop as before I mean
things haven't even decided to very at
all it's just the same repetitive loop
I've been doing for about three four
minutes now maybe I was supposed to
branch off or else I'm just gonna be
stuck in a repetitive loop for the rest
of my existence in this plane no not
about your side of this guy good night
my okay okay I thought it was okay okay
just one life left let's see how we can
waste it
okay obviously the repetitive always
you're not gonna beat the timer if there
is an exit so let's take that branching
path and go there oh I thought I was
safe I wasn't safe I was not okay oh man
I can only say that I hope this records
correctly just wandering halls waiting
until my death comes hoping that it'll
be a quick end I've only got one life
left so who knows what's gonna happen
when I lose this one probably not fun
times probably means that I couldn't
escape purgatory and am stuck here
eternally damned in these brick and
mortar walls okay here's the first
branching path so if I go down this way
I am now sprinting the whole time and
take as many branching paths as I can
hopefully okay that's where the monster
first appeared that's when yeah I went
wobbly and now it's not wobbly I just
noticed okay so take as many branching
paths as I can I think this is another
one and just keep moving forward I'm
twitching my leg I don't know if you
guys can hear me kind of anxious idea I
think this might not be
one of the paths I was supposed to take
but let's keep going cuz I'm totally
lost and there's no way that I'm gonna
be able to remember any of this
I really wish they could have done
something better with the Texas because
those textures up there just the same
repetitive thing going from black to
whatever other thing I mean they could
have done a little bit better everything
is the same grungy texture I mean I
understand that cela not that way I
understand that people have to UM you
know with these indie games there's not
a lot of time for them to put into it
but I mean you could put a little more
detail into the environment it's a small
touches to a game that really adds
something to it I mean the environment
itself ah-ha it was scared of me go
right into the ground
sucka little did he know I was totally
helpless
but anyway because the environment
itself in this particular game is not
that immersive or all that interesting I
don't even know why there's brick on the
ceiling that doesn't seem right it's
illogical in a lot of ways well then
again games don't have to be logical I'm
not saying they have to be pretty I'm
just saying after oh come on baby
I'll just game over that's it I think I
pulled something in my neck
yeah how do you even load a game I don't
know oh all right that's it for now I'm
done I'm done okay so thank you
everybody so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos it I've done
God and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye oh ah oh oh you can
make it like a little buddy take it I
got the water there we go